e aí galera que este campeonato com
vocês militar todo bom não é essa hoje o
dia foi intenso para quem não sabe onde
errou o segundo dia do enem exame
nacional de ensino médio que é a prova
que mede a inteligência do jovem
brasileiro ou a burrice né caso ele
queira pode ter uma foto da prova antes
de fazer eu vou contar o quanto que foi
tenso o meu dia de hoje eu acordei taleh
com todo o dia e fui bater com minha
família e tal aí eu fui pegar o ônibus
não é só que hoje é domingo e de domingo
se passar um único de cinco em cinco
horas
é milagre pereira esperei esperar para
começar a ficar eu comecei a ficar tenso
e eu comecei a ficar com olhos só você
fica com um olho no seu coração eu já
estava com raiva é minha casa meu lado e
me trouxe meu filho shopping passa por
aqui eu já estava com raiva ou essa
mulher para a senhora que a 1 e eu nunca
vi o shopping passará por oito ônibus
que passa pelo shopping para porque mal
shopping não passe o pior em xeque o
ônibus aqui em teresina ele demorou
muito para sair quando ele passa passa
15 de uma vez aí vem aquela rua de
ônibus fazendo a curva silva poder vir
pra cá henry não era o meu pai não era o
meu passou eu passou ou não um deus que
pode acreditar quando vi a [ __ ] do meu
ônibus passa outro ano papéis on ice
demorou demorou demorou pronto aí onde
peguei um anos entrei bonitinho cheguei
lá dentro o rapaz não sabe o que é tipo
assim a população de tóquio inteira
dentro de um ônibus
eu estava lá eu tenho que colocar em
ônibus lotados em cadeia que por lei não
passar no meio dos outros três motores
está no violência
já a partir de janeiro eles caminhão
descarrega bota não tá nem sentia se um
bode normal o time sentir o teu bode do
mundo não só para que o motorista tinha
não sei se o motorista tinha brigado com
a esposa acertar com diego é uma coisa
de quem estava escutando em que o rei na
frente
o motorista fazia coro por um lado é uma
chapéu na hora que ele fazia quando o
popular leonel rocha tema deixando de
pagar imi nos levando a juventus não o
documento que tem aqui tá falando m
só que o homem não parava se na frente
da escola tinham eram um pouco de
história sentar com medo de ser roubado
não tenho vontade de ir à escola chegou
na escola perguntei quanto é o cara
falou r$9 não mas não é nenhum tipo de
roubo do kaká veio bem sabe que você é a
distância do meu quarto a cozinha do
tipo tomou impedido de levar um pouco da
gol preto cobrar 15 reais por cada um
desses um moto táxi é gente que se
aproveita um dia e nem de ferro potássio
no a7 aí eu falei assim toma aqui viu
muito obrigado por me trazer aqui o
trabalho senhor viu mais o deus da vila
tomara que a desgraça de se ter um furo
e platão aí eu cheguei lá e fui fazer a
prova sentei à escala da minha sala
esqueceu de entregar a prova na hora
certa e ficar esperando bater no final
lá pra entregar provas em que neste
momento quer aproveitar a atual mesa aí
começa a rasgar tudo rápido deixar
provocar no chão em torno de 90
inventando por graça mais sério caiu
ninguém poderá ver esta prova eu pensei
que no ano passado estava difícil você é
ídolo lá não tiver achando fácil
aproximam mas eu achei que passou eu não
sou você meu socorro que é fácil pra
você pode ser difícil pra mim tá então
por favor respeite as diferenças porque
ser diferente é normal após às questões
de português o que ela não sabe se está
levando a questão do enem ou a saga
crepúsculo é que ela não é a bíblia a
série tanto difícil para o amor de deus
aquela questão vem pra ficar pior só
faltou justifique ação nesse porte ou
defeitos no esporte o que foge na coisa
de outro médico responde eu já respondi
carrega justificar o que mais pra falar
a verdade a prova tem que ser difícil
mesmo é eu que sou ingênuo pensar que eu
vou chegar lá e vai ter um complexo la
com os matemáticos nem se fala cada peça
da série house um concerto de regra de
três multiplicação e divisão é
a questão é assim sabendo que os carros
só uma lancha usada uma só como jet skis
e os pedestres com os banhistas calcular
mas do seu contato de pai eu usei aquela
fórmula básica que eu inventei é o
cálculo hipotético universal técnico
estimativo mais conhecido como o chute
onde é muito boa é você deixar o
gabarito bonito você vai marcando um
bebê mas não sei
a marca assim dois bem seguidos da yzf
button é claro de que não tem
preconceito com o término o gabarita
bonitinho dava passar mas é isso que
queremos compartilhar meu dia que você
se você gostou de saber que tem que
fazer
são jóias aquele cheirinho delicioso
coxim e pé de moleque serenata de amor
jóia eu quero que você comente aqui a
coisa mais bizarra que você já passou
enquanto fazia uma prova que você não tá
escrito esse canal cliquei inscrever-se
clicando em inscrever se esconde de novo
você vai saber
é nóis assistir se vir até aqui